as a reminder we are watching the
Norwegian Championship Main Event the
2023 Norwegian Championship main event
here at card Casino Bratislava
is one of the most pure Poker events out
there a five-day main event with two
opening fights players have one bullet
throughout so a pure freeze out fewer
poker
very rare especially in Europe but even
very rare anywhere around the globe
but this is how poker should be played
and Magnus Carlson
with the Snowman opening to 4 500.
and could be in a rough spot with
forbrook waking up with the pocket
rockets
poor Brook not playing them so at all
raising to 11
000 to five and a half big binds
from the small Bond
Carlson is in position so he can't just
call if he wants but based on a stack he
can't shop what I don't think he will do
is fold although that would perhaps save
him if he could if he can find the right
read about poorberg but that's very
difficult for Brick should be betting
with a lot more hands
and Carlson does call
oh my God Magnus Carlson here gets a
dream pop of King eight nine
flopping the bottom set here now if Fort
Burke was pulling this move with Ace
King Carlson knows that this is amazing
now meanwhile horbrook has even better
than Ace King he has the pocket rockets
what a dream for Magnus Carlson peeling
off that three bet
forberg leading out after three betting
his Rockets now how is Carlson going to
approach this it's still even though it
is a rainbow board that eight nine does
connect with some of his opponents
Holdings for a draw are we going to see
a call or a race by the chess Legend
Magnus Carlson
Carlson thinking through his options or
perhaps trying to disguise the strength
of his hand
will just call I like this a lot
you don't want your opponent to fold and
the King of Spades on the turn improves
Carlson further to a Full House
he might be praying now that his
opponent has Ace King
Warburg however
may actually slow down to some degree
but he can never really be folding his
Aces here
not to somebody as smart as Carlson who
could be floating and deciding what to
do next but does check this slow down
now it's going to be up the cross and to
try to get more value out of this hand
there are a couple cards on the river
that can actually be Crossing not just
the two Aces but the two remaining Kings
would both get four Burke a full house
but he doesn't know what four Burke has
but even if they put four Burke on an
Ace King type of hand those cards would
still apply but it said it's a queen of
hearts on the river
Carlson checking it back once again
disguising how strong his hand is
let's see at Fort Burke thinks he's
ahead that would be the only reason why
he would put more chips in
Carlson has a little more than a pot
sized bet behind
and forbeck reaching for his chips 18.
betting 18 000 into a pot of forty two
thousand
[Music]
what a Poker Face by Magnus Carlson
looking a little tripled by that bet
but expect them to come over the top
obviously now he's losing to some King
Queens as well so we'll see how he
approaches it
shouldn't be concerned so much about the
king nine king eight but those are
possibilities as well but forberg
wouldn't have been three betting those I
don't believe he's been playing fairly
close to the best and for him to be
three betting king queen would have been
out of character for four Burke as well
so Carlson should still feel he has the
best hand here
possibly just disguising this with the
waiting time to make it appear like he
would be bluffing when he jumps in a
stack which is what I think he will do
I'd be shocked if he just calls
he does just call though folks
he could have gotten more value but
still cracked floorberg's Aces to get
back over his starting stack 113
000 the chess Legend has now
near the end of day 1B does seem
disappointed he didn't get more value
but did get quite nice value none of